our productive visit during which
we have strengthened the close ties
that unite our two countries and work
with other leaders on
the most pressing issues
above them
you release a moment of time has passed
and if he asks quite  y ensure
that a center of christchurch
president of the global community must
take an approach courses given to
illuminate the
terrorist and extremist content found
online it is clear that platforms
have a responsibility to ensure
that their technology  not be
used to spread is Korean or
disseminate acts of violence noting
that doing now we must also do
our part including enforcing the
law
if companies refuse to act
the call to action is an
important and fundamental step to  ensure
everyone's safety online, but we
must also develop solutions
china or at the national level
we must implement a
global strategy that will allow us to
regulate the digital space
the reality is that the internet and
new digital technologies have an
impact on all aspects of our lives
but since the digital space is
still not regulated regulating people
is  in a vulnerable position in the face
of disturbing trends for
echoes government must act
after all we can not only
rely on companies to
protect the public interest
that is why our government has
stepped up investigations that target the
groups  haters and extremists have
continued to be thuir new
measures to prevent foreign stewards
in our electoral process
weeks
thank you very much I am now only to
answer your questions
on the weekend of the grand prix
yes it is our priority in any
situation c  is to always do
things that will help you and Canadian
in difficulty
we will always continue to do
do only the things that we know
good and canadians
[Music]
with
I think people recognize that
the international aspect the global aspect
of the internet demands that we see
forgiveness with each other for what
'we are doing at home
our vision of our solutions because
it is certainly by
working together with each other
we will better achieve aa regulated to
protect citizens everywhere in the
world but as a government
canadian main responsibility
is to protect canadians to
ensure that we are defending
the rights of citizens while
ensuring their safety it
is something that a government
must do what  this government is
still doing it we will continue to
look at what we can do i
will be there at minister baird's wedding
soon on this digital charter
for canada
[Music]
on one of the ministers there was some good
p  arent of
if i take you back to china these people there
have relatives people who to
say canada can not do much about
this big dispute between china and
the united states is what in fact
canadians and the price for these  disputes
i think people understand
so china has an approach towards the
system of rules and laws and
principles that govern international trade of
international relations
that is not aligned
with the vast majority of western democracies
having to stand together  for has
shown that we are not with changing
our values our principles of others our way o
acting particularly with regar
to the independence of our justi
e system because the Chine
e government has chosen to act
arbitrarily and and detain
canadians we will continue to
defend these canadians we will
continue to support these canadians
we will continue to say clearly
to china that their  actions are
unacceptable oh yes so precise on
the internet
there are canadians who see the
efforts to regulate the words a void
and violent extremism as a form
of censorship can you
explain to us who will determine where are
buried
is this  what it is the government that
wants to do and how to manage to
determine its limits and I think that
we know that we are talking about dangerous
extremely complex and difficult it is
always an issue is to find the
right balance between defending
rights and freedoms  that canadians
learn hold sichel and the
responsibility to keep people
safe in their community and in
their lives finding that balance takes a
lot of thought a lot
of partnership consultation and that's
exactly what we're
doing to be able to  announced the
measures with which we will
move forward but I know that the
canadian finds it unacceptable
that nadie
extremism and so easily annoyed
on the internet
we will do our part to
ensure that all
internet users are better protected
against these forms of violence which
unfortunately we find too good day
80 cases almost
and again its announcement so I transform
you also have the
human highlight of salty money but we
know that canada is going it alone
next to the
damman states I was wondering what
the real impact in your opinion of the call for
prestige as our neighbors gadahn
auch and we know that the united states will
continue to make its own
decision just like every country
but i want to highlight the number of countries
that have joined the call of
christchurch who believe deeply that
we can  and must work
together to ensure the safety of
citizens online to counter this
rise in violence and extremism that
we too often find on our internet and
we know that being in the compagn  ie
of his daughters who were around the
table yesterday, in particular a beautiful season
for France and Great Britain but
also others such as
Japan Australia who are also committed to
the call of Christchurch citizens
around the world  know that we have
to act and we are going to act together
on board a whole subject you have always
said you etc these feminists that you
support the choice of women
concerning abortion
precisely speaking of the United States we see
that there are significant setbacks  especially
from alabama I was wondering what do
you know how to deal with six
for women's rights and from
home we deeply regret that there
are still places in the world
including our American neighbors where
are in the process  to back down in the defense
of women's rights for us for
our government
we should always defend the rights
of women we could should always
protect the right of women to choose
for themselves  s in the street for me we
will continue to be a strong voice for
the defense of the rights of everyone
is also due especially others in the
world and it is a job that remains to be
done is last of the work that remains  to
do
[Applause]
[Music]
hello from a moment from radio france
internationale just one more
clarification on the chinese file is
that canada is considering concrete measures
on the diplomatic
or economic level, like
what  was decided by washington
regarding huawei in relation to the
ce king and 5 g
decision we are making our decisions based on the
facts based on the analysis done by our
intelligence and security services
we believe that these decisions votes
policies to make past decisions
about our understanding of
how to keep our citizens safe
while providing them with choices they have
left so in the
technological years available to them
it is a  decision that we take very
seriously and that we continue on which we
continue on
I find